salut c'est monsieur grrrr aujourd'hui
je vous prends quelque chose qu'il est
globalement pas banal votre smartphone
samsung en verrez vos photos
personnelles vos photos intimes au
hasard à vos contacts
imaginez vous dormez vous avez passé une
soirée incroyable votre téléphone est
posé à côté de vous vous dormez
tranquillement pendant que votre
smartphone envoie au hasard avant
contacts à tous vos contacts ou du moins
quelques contacts sélectionnés au hasard
on ne sait pas comment par l'opération
du saint-esprit
vos photos les plus intimes alors pas
forcément vos sextape vous sépare
commandes ivo sexe pictures mais en tout
cas vos photos au hasard à vos contacts
c'est quand même hyper hyper hyper hyper
sensible hyper craignos je sais pas si
on dit encore craignos en 2018
en tout cas ça peut vraiment poser
problème en tout cas c'est ce qui semble
être arrivé à plusieurs personnes qui se
sont plaintes sur différents forums que
ce soit sur reddit que ce soit sur le
forum officiel de samsung
là vous avez le message serait dit mon
ex ne plus envoyer toutes mes photos à
ma petite copine la nuit dernière quand
je dormais vous êtes toute la discussion
effectivement sur reddit qui est ici où
il explique un petit peu le problème est
là vous avez un message sur le forum de
samsung samsung community oui parce elle
explique un petit peu le problème
qu'elle a rencontré verrerie de guy tu
m'étonnes la réponse de sam sont
derrière une petite discussion possible
trouver la solution
une des personnes à dix pendant que je
dormais mon smartphone envoyer toutes
mes photos à un seul de mes contacts
c'est à ma petite amie
ça reste dans la sphère intime donc pour
coussin particulièrement posé de
problème
une autre personne s'est plainte en
disant que c'est arrivé également à sa
femme ça lui arrive et la nuit d'avant
toutes ces personnes là pour point
commun d'avoir un smartphone samsung
galaxy alors ce serait pas arrivé à des
modèles forcément trop anciens ça serait
arrivé d'ailleurs aux notes 8 os 9 et à
différents modèles
si vos photos intimes sont envoyés à des
personnes très proches on peut imaginer
que ça pose pas forcément trop trop trop
trop problème si c'est votre mère qui
reçoit une photo de votre chien pourquoi
pas par contre s'il reçoit une de vos
photos avec votre petite amie dans des
positions
un petit peu ambigu ça peut rapidement
poser problème imaginez maintenant si
votre boss reçoit la photo de votre
dernière partie de jambes en l'air ça
peu un petit peu aussi vous
décrédibiliser et alors que dire si ça
arrive à un de vos prospects 6 arrive à
un de vos clients
c'est ensuite être relativement
compliqué ça peut aussi compliquer
rapidement les problèmes si c'est votre
femme qui reçoit les photos de bouillie
votre maîtresse attention je dis pas que
voir maîtresse au contraire ça vous
apprendra la trompe et c'est bien fait
pour vous a priori ce qui pourrait poser
problème c'est l'application samsung
message rencontrerez un bug sauf que ce
bug ne laisserait aucune trace dans les
log donc aucun moyen d'identifier tout
de suite le problème est vraiment dire
c'est l'application samsung message
attendant c'est vraiment le point commun
entre les différents personnes qui se
sont plaints de ce problème
samsung est informé du bugue cherche à
l'identifier à savoir si effectivement
ça vienne chez eux
oui ou non en attendant on a deux
solutions qui sont relativement simples
pour éviter que ça vous arrive
la toute première ceux de retirer
l'autorisation à l'application samsung
message d'accéder à vos photos comme ça
l'application pourra plus envoyez vos
photos
vu qu'il n'aura plus accès et la
deuxième solution c'est de passer par
une application tierce pour l'envoi de
messages android message vouloir pouvoir
pâte extra en existe plusieurs
pour l'heure rien ne prouve que ça vient
de samsung que c'est effectivement un
bug inhérents à la marque même si le
point commun entre tous les plaignants
viennent du fait qu'ils ont un samsung
galaxy ce que ce problème montrer ce qui
est vraiment intéressant c'est que crois
que nos infos sont toujours sécurisées
on croit que nos photos stockées dans
notre appareil soit sécurisé donc on ne
fait pas n'importe quoi mais ça peut
vous bien que non on n'est jamais à
l'abri d'un bug on n'est jamais à l'abri
d'un piratage nous données personnelles
sont toujours sensibles même si on les
conserve tranquillement dans son
smartphone ou sur un ordinateur
moralité de l'invention à vos données
personnelles photos comptes e-mails tout
ce que vous voulez si vous voulez pas
voir une mauvaise surprise pour ma part
je connais personne à qui c'est arrivé
j'ai aucune personne tournoi qui s'en
sont plaintes ou pas identifié mise à
part ces quelques personnes que j'ai pu
voir sur reddick ou sur le forum de
samsung au delà de ça je connais
personne d'ailleurs est ce que ça vous
est arrivé est ce que ça arrivait à des
personnes proches de vous est ce
qu'elles sont déjà rencontrés ce bug est
ce qu'elles ont rencontré ce problème
est-ce que c'est clairement identifié
comme un bug de samsung mark et moi
directement tous en haut comme en terre
cuite
autre question par extension un peu plus
large est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
problèmes avec des photos sensible des
photos intimes qui ont été envoyés à des
tierces personnes qui auraient été
récupérées pirater les choses qui
craignent un peu marre qui va tout ça en
commentaire comme d'hab véritable essai
des jolies
ça vous a volé parce que paraît toujours
plus de teck d'infos tech de pas mal de
choses et je bosse à fond sur la rentrée
croyez moi n'y avoir pas mal de
surprises ça va être cool
restez connectés d'ici là soyez ça je
vous embrasse et prenez soin de vous
ciao
[Musique]